now we begin this hour with an open and
honest conversation on mental health
with some of the biggest names in
professional sports we've recently
reported on two elite women athletes
simone biles and naomi osaka who are
stepping away from their sports over
their mental health concerns nearly 20
percent of american adults are facing
mental health challenges this morning
you'll hear from three athletes nba
superstar kevin love who has spoken
openly about his anxiety and depression
also six-time nfl pro bowler brandon
marshall back in 2011 he shared that he
was diagnosed with borderline
personality disorder and wnba rookie
dede richards who was part of a new
generation of athletes speaking up about
injuries that go beyond the physical
richards was temporarily paralyzed
during a college practice in 2020 and
she says she's still dealing with it
emotionally that is trauma that is
sitting in i sit down with all three who
want everyone to know that it's okay it
is okay to be vulnerable
when did you feel like being vulnerable
was okay so i was diagnosed with
borderline personality disorder the best
way to describe borderline personality
disorders emotional disorder most people
who are living with borderline
personality disorder
they don't have the skills and tools
naturally to be able to cope in and
manage self-regulate for me i had to go
through self-assessment to pick up those
tools and skills to be able to
communicate what i was feeling i didn't
have that naturally it was just all
about reacting not responding
now kevin you've said that there was
times where you wondered why you were so
concerned what other people thought when
did that shift happen
shift happened probably
in 2017 i had to have a
major moment in my life a very public
emotional
and mental health moment which was a
panic attack
on the floor you ran
and you collapsed on the trainer's floor
and from there you tried to gather
yourself you said you thought you were
about to die
i thought i was having a cardiac moment
honestly i mean the oxygen just just
wasn't going
to my brain my lungs i just wasn't
getting you know i was nothing was
alleviating the the panic that i was
feeling so i actually ended up on on
oxygen after that went to the cleveland
clinic all the tests checked out so to
me i'm thinking well what the hell just
happened
i was taught to compartmentalize i was
taught to
you know not speak about it not show
weakness i think as athletes we can all
confide in that and understand that in a
way and you know it's funny because
every few years i i kind of see my
myself i look in the mirror i wasn't
passing the mirror test now i'm doing a
little bit better more comfortable my
own skin and i can say hey listen if i
if i'm feeling triggers if i'm feeling
something i know
my tools and what i can go to you just
said something interesting and what you
said was you know i did all this work
and i wasn't passing the mirror test
then now sometimes i do because when you
think about this entire thing right as
athletes we get up every single day and
what do we do
we try to fight as hard as
possible to train our bodies to jump
higher to run faster to be stronger so
every day if we're going to put that
much work into our bodies right
physically what are we doing mentally
right there's spiritual warfare
there's mental anxiety and then there's
physical trauma
dede
you had an injury that was
life-changing
[Applause]
[Music]
paralyzation right
[Applause]
you're sitting in a hospital
forget about basketball right
you're most likely thinking to yourself
am i ever gonna walk again what was
going through your head when that
happened
it happened so fast you know like you
said in the blink of an eye something
you love and that you do every day was
the reason why you're sitting in this
hospital so it took a toll on me
mentally to where as soon as i got hurt
that's all i could think about was
basketball so it took some time when i
take some time i'm still going through
it you know and
i'll sit there and i'm just like
dude you're still hurting from this or
do you never allowed yourself to really
cope with what you went through
as athletes they think we're robots you
get hurt okay they're just hurt they'll
be back you know and i started thinking
like that like okay i got hurt yes but
i'm coming back instead of thinking i'm
hurt i need to figure out how i'm going
to deal with this and how i am feeling
deep down inside because as a black
female you're taught to swallow that you
know what i'm saying you just swallow it
and you figure it out on your own
and it wasn't until recently when i say
recently like a couple months ago where
my um college coach is like
dede you're you're not the same like
you're you're not okay because i'm this
happy person i've always been this happy
person but it was to the point where i
took my craft so seriously that i would
just
forget what you're thinking in your head
forget the world feeling sorry for you
that doesn't mean anything it's now you
have to go and you know work harder you
miss 38 days being paralyzed now it's
time to go back in the gym and you know
train harder you said something that
struck me you said as a black woman
which is as real as it gets
when you said that that came from
somewhere deep
what do you mean by that
you go through things and it's kind of
it gets to a point where
we're sitting here and we could be
hurting right in front of you you know
but
if you ask us what's wrong it's going to
be nothing how are you but it's just
something that you've been raised you've
been brought up as and it's especially
as an athlete at that it's like it's so
many things adding on to a female a
black female an athlete it's like now
you're pushed way down into the at
you're at the bottom now you're the last
person you're thinking about even if it
comes to yourself
so i want to speak on isolation now with
the pandemic
and people finding themselves alone do
you think that
exacerbated
the struggles and have you guys been in
situations where you were alone
and
maybe your
depression or anxiety got the best of
you
sports is a microcosm of society no
doubt right
so we don't
think about the like 2020 the pandemic
for the very first time we all were
dealing with the same thing and having
these conversations anxiety depression
there were so many people dealing with
that for the very first time had no clue
what that was or what they were feeling
to work right they couldn't leave their
house they had to deal i think that's
the huge takeaway is
connect with the trauma so i never dealt
with anxiety ever
i had my first panic attack in a
pandemic wow really yes what happened
so i
december
got covet covet 19
and i'm sitting in my bedroom isolation
and i just remember this thing coming
over me where i couldn't breathe
and all i could think about is like oh
my goodness if
something if this continues to happen
then i'm gonna have to go to the
hospital and they put me on a ventilator
and then what happens if i'm under now i
can't control it and all i could think
about is like i just want my wife to
come in here i was like if she can just
come in here and let me just hold on to
her leg i just need someone to touch me
i just need to
you know the to be here with physical
touch no one could come in that room
yeah i remember just like you know what
let me use my skills and tools that i
learned i was like i know it's going to
be okay
this is not a heart attack i feel like
i'm dying but i'm not going to die
right and just understanding what it
what it was was it allowed me to be able
to get through that moment right there's
some that will sit back and say
first world problems
i mean you got the money
you get paid to deal with the bs right
how bad is life really right but
something that you guys have all said at
one point or the other it's uh success
is not immune
to depression that's right
so mental health issues right not bias
to doesn't discriminate to who has money
or who doesn't yeah if you're an athlete
or not right so just speak on that
perspective because you guys deal with
certain things and not only you dealing
with it but you're dealing with it in
the public eye right which almost
magnifies it and intensifies it right we
have to understand that
social anxiety is a real thing
naomi osaka she's dealing with a real
thing right so is the sport bigger than
her life her well-being
her life how many more athletes
entertainers or just people
you know are going to continue to be
isolated right because of their truth or
what they're dealing with there are
people out there that are struggling
struggling in silence so we have to
embrace this right we're just not used
to having those conversations so when
naomi opens up she's bringing more
people to the sport because we're
humanizing her and they identify with
her there you go
i want to say thank you to the athletes
for being transparent and for those
watching out i would encourage you to
resist the urge to see them as athletes
just see them as somebody that could be
going through the same thing you or a
loved one is going through because
athletes we just parallel what's going
on in society
and like i said 20 of americans deal
with some type of mental issue mental
health issue on a daily basis i'm so
glad that they spoke up the way they did
dede richards i went to see the liberty
last month she was so good i had no idea
about her back story brandon and kevin
we have heard their stories too but the
fact that they opened up the way they
did and spoke so candidly yeah it'll
help only all this does nate is help
other people it definitely helps other
people and didi said they see us as
robots uh that goes for a lot of people
working a lot of jobs there you go and
they're you know i think that message
should be more broadly accepted not only
among athletes but for all workers and
speaking of that if you or someone you
know is seeking mental health resources
you can call the national alliance on
mental illness helpline at
1-800-950-6264
or in a crisis text nami to 741-741